can we have some breaking news now and
President Biden has fallen over on stage
at a U.S Air Force graduation ceremony
the president was helped to his feeds
before making his way back to his seat
unassisted that was at the U.S Air Force
Academy in Colorado you can see there
Joe Biden falling over
well our U.S correspondent markstone
joins me from Washington uh Mark what
more can you tell us
uh well the first thing to say is that
he is fine uh his uh press uh direct
director of communications Ben labolt
has just tweeted a response to a video
that has been posted online the one you
just saw which says he's fine there was
a sandbag on stage while he was shaking
hands um that the only official comment
we've had up from the White House he
does appear to get up straight away he
then goes to his seat where he is seen
talking
um with uh other members of the um uh
the gathered crowd there this was at the
Falcon stadium in Colorado Springs he
was there at the 2023 U.S Air Force
Academy graduation ceremony and this was
towards the end of that um event now now
why is this newsworthy um because uh it
is simply an accident well because
already online
um the Republican party is making
something of this there is a a view
widespread view among many uh in the
Republican party but among voters as
well that the pro president is is simply
too old to run again for office that
some say he is losing control of his
faculties and this will be used as
evidence of that
um the it's true also though to say that
he as president gets regular Medicals
there is no evidence at all so to
suggest that he is medically either
physically or mentally unfit and that
this like other Falls that he has had
and that anyone can have that is simply
that an accidental fall in this case
tripping over a sandbag but make no
mistake this as with other instances
where he either appears to lose his
train of thought remember he is a man
who has suffered all his life from
having a stutter and he has has overcome
that that is the excuse for why people
say he sometimes loses his train of
thought but as I say this and other
instances will be used by the rights on
politics in in what is an increasingly
uh bitterly um fought presidential
campaign that may uh yet be 18 months
away it will be used against him but the
Top Line um from Ben labolt his uh
Communications secretary he's fine there
was a sandbag on stage while he was
shaking hands